When you go to the interview,
especially for Android positions,
I think it's important to have, and
spend some effort in putting together
a portfolio of what you built.
A lot of times people just refer
you to their GitHub account, and
they'll have a ton of repose.
None of them have been touched,
or they're not complete.
So, I think, when you structure it,
structure it, maybe, if you can,
build a portfolio page of apps that
you've developed in your GitHub page,
think of them the same way.
So put in screenshots.
Not everyone's going to build your apps.
But people are going
to look at your code.
So put in some description of,
in the read me, so that people can see
initially of what the app does,
what it was targeted, why you built it.
I think those are all important things.
Because when I get a developer, one of
the first things I do after I talk to
them or even beforehand is look at their
GitHub page and look at their code,
because I think that gives you
a sense of, they have no restrictions.
This is how they would
program on their own and
the quality of the code they produce.
When you're interviewing for
a job, they're also looking for
a company that's right fit for you.
So I think it's important and depending
on the company, they might be willing or
not willing to do it.
But getting a sense of
the culture is important, and
also if you can,
getting a sense of the code base.
If you can look at the code and kind of
see how developers are developing within
that company, and if you think it's
something where it looks promising that
you could learn a great deal from,
you should definitely go into it.